hello my name is yeska I'm a pretty cool
dog that loves to chill I am five years
old and loves skateboarding with my
owner you skateboard you're Cooler Than
Me we'll do trick for treats Amber is
the color of my energy like my coat
let's see what kind of tricks you can do
oh she's peeing oh oh okay sit
oh wow see
okay pop
oh good oh you're so good oh do you want
belly rub do you want belly rub
I think we're best friends now I think
Jessica likes me the fact that you can
do tricks and that you're so beautifully
groomed and you're so cool means that
you have a very dedicated boner and you
guys probably have a great relationship
and I'm jealous